[Music]
there are over 1300 endangered or
threatened species in the u.s today but
many though teetering on the edge of
extinction safely live on millions of
acres held in trust by the federal
government and some of that land isn't
as remote as you might think in fact if
you're an air traveler you may have
driven or flown right by it
san francisco international airport may
seem to be an unlikely place to protect
an endangered species but in a grassy
area flanked by runways natalie reeder
spends her days combing through brush to
make sure nature is on track to thrive
here's one you can see on the leaf here
the little frog is actually a key part
of the food chain that keeps a rare
garter snake alive the snakes are just a
native species
this is one of the few places left on
the san francisco peninsula where they
can survive so
it's the airport's responsibility to
take care of the population and the
habitat where they live long before she
was required by federal law to wear a
mask on airport property reader san
francisco international's biologist in
residence was trying to save the garter
snakes from extinction the garter snakes
bright blue orange and black markings
are considered among the most beautiful
in the world i like snakes i think
because they're the ultimate underdog
and everybody hates them
so
you know they're just a really
interesting animal
that
is misunderstood so i think that drives
me to want to protect them because they
don't have a lot of advocates
the unsuspecting travelers who get on
and off 1300 flights here a day would
surely be surprised to learn of the
lengths the airport commission has gone
to accommodate snakes for starters 180
acres have been set aside and fenced in
just for them when you think about
airport lands they would typically
always be developed for airport
operations for airplanes for terminals
hotels whereas here we are intentionally
leaving this land
in its most natural state and actually
doing things to avoid erosion to avoid
flooding of waters doug yaakel is the
airport spokesman we actually need to
cut that grass down to reduce the fire
risk rather than bringing in heavy
machinery we actually hire a team of
goats
that come onto the land for two weeks
and essentially eat up all the grass to
avoid the fire hazard so it's just
another example of how a very modern
high-tech airport is using some very
low-tech solutions to preserve the space
and san francisco's airport is not the
only one in the rare species protection
business in oregon portland's airport is
caring for the federally threatened
street-corned lark not to be outdone lax
has the federally protected el segundo
blue butterfly and to welcome travelers
to the big apple jfk has the diamondback
terrapins which are slowing the pace in
a city that never sleeps people get into
the mindset that you have to go to
nature
but this place really shows just how
much nature is all around us and that
even a property that looks kind of dumpy
can have a really rare endangered
species doing well on it this year san
francisco airport's efforts achieved a
milestone the u.s geological survey and
the u.s fish and wildlife service report
a resurgence in the airport's garter
snakes making it the world's largest
population of the rare snakes in a place
that otherwise would have been paved
over
and that's another indication of how
climate change is really
changing the impact of you know where
these species can live and thrive you
know it's getting drier in california
the prey that they eat
is all but gone i like her line about
snakes being the ultimate underdog i
know i do feel badly i do think there
are a few people at least that like them
out there yeah i've discovered snakes
and wolves are two of the most hated
creatures we love both look a little
like snakes like a brother of a
herpetologist so grow up with snakes in
the house learn how to deal i love that